comment ça va les chéris superbe série
le merci ça soit je vois super série
mercy da 200 pour sa te dire je t'aime
et tu as fait une émission
exceptionnelle à scandale l'accord se
mettent d'accord ce mec
agathe alors on venait de plus dans tpm
dès maintenant vous êtes dans balances
ton post c'est un petit peu les prépas
hec
ça va vous la péter pas trop non ça va
vous êtes contente de revenir voir vos
camarades quand même bien évidemment
tout le monde vous a manqué allez autour
de la table le monde autour de la table
ce périmètre la également à tout le
monde dans ce périmètre la gagne m'a
manqué tout le monde dans ce périmètre
légalement surtout mathieu ma nature
vous a manqué les bateaux et il ne
manque à personne c'est bien les bacs
avoue qu'il a manqué merci monsieur à
l'ailé si on va passer au jt des médias
vous réagissez sur vous avec nous on est
très content que vous soyez là c'est
parti de gîtes et des médias